chuck chuck listen to me i know he's
killing me the 20 000 people in the
arena know he's killing me my teammates
knows he's killing me we all know he's
killing me
[Music]
curry steps in takes a teardrop and he's
got
a little pump fake little fly by
so when we talk about great shooters of
today we talk about
shooting off the dribble and you know
coming off screens getting a shot moving
without the basketball running around
catch you the greatest shooter you know
by far i think he's already been stamped
got the tag steph curry okay so i'm
gonna go back to to my arrow and i'm
gonna talk to you about mark price
twice revving it up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
mark price off the pick-and-roll one of
the greatest shooters i've ever seen
in our game
now there's a thing we call 50 40 90.
guy shoots 50 from the field
40 from the three 90 from the line that
was mark price back then mark price can
come off screens he can catch it he can
shoot it but
then he was fast and he was quick and he
could run all day and then there's this
thing now where they split the screen
but mark price was coming off and he was
splitting the screen and then he's
pulling up popping
excuse me
from the three-point line
his shot making his foul shooting and
then his speed made him like almost
unguardable during that era
price over isaiah from deep he got
another triple to go we were at the
palace and we were playing against
cleveland and mark price he was killing
me the first quarter chuck daley calls
time out i come to the bench chuck goes
isaiah mark's killing you he's killing
you i'm like yeah i'm gonna get it
together and so we go back out
mark price
hits another three quick call timeout we
come to the bench chuck goes
mark is killing you isaiah like you you
got to do something i say hey chuck
chuck listen to me i know he's killing
me the 20 000 people in the arena know
he's killing me my teammates knows he's
killing me
can you tell me something that's gonna
help me right now to stop this dude from
killing me because we all know he's
killing me
splits two defenders
to fly by it's a three balls
this is a big leap just in terms of
watching steph today shoot the
basketball and comparing him to price
because you can't really make that as an
accurate comparison because steph curry
has done something so uniquely different
in our league what mark price was doing
so difficult and rare back then and
those things in our league they were
just starting to appear so when we see
that happening today you know you always
have to give the originators the ones
who started it the pioneers you always
have to go back and remind people of
what really sparked the imagination of
players and of coaches to incorporate
these things basketball in a lot of ways
is a lot like music they say there's no
such thing as new music there's new ways
of using it but as earthwind and fire
said
sounds never dissipate
it only recreates in another place and
basketball is the same way